Logan is in Detroit welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show Logan hey I was going better
than I deserve sir how can I help I just
had a question I'm getting married here
in about 45 days and I'm only 20 years
old and I'm supposed to I called a house
tomorrow I didn't know if it was a good
idea with my financial situation well if
you're contracted too close you've
signed a contract I don't know if it
matters or sign your closing yes however
I can back out up and he's still closing
well guys don't want
that's just my realtor told me to be
honest I'm sorry I like that's what my
realtor told me well yeah you you can
back out but you could get sued for
backing out because you've signed a
contract and the contract says that
you've agreed to buy a piece of property
and if unless there's the thing that
says I change and listeners are not
change my mind clause in the contract is
is there some kind of an out in the
contract that gives you an out I reading
it said I could back out and get my
deposit back up until the day of closing
for any reason any reason yes Kri sure
that's a highly unusual real estate
contract most contracts are there to
cause you to you know you've agreed to
buy somebody's house they've agreed to
sell it to you and you're contractually
bound to do so if the element I mean if
you get your financing and you get your
elements or the contract are met
okay so let's pretend that that this is
true it's unusual but it's possible that
you can just walk away
of course the seller is not going to be
happy right no no I'm thinking not yeah
they think they have their house sold
and they think there's a closing
tomorrow
how much is the house the house we're
buying it for 134,000 and what is your
income and what's her income my income
roughly before overtime was about 40
grand a year gross and hers and her and
her incomes about 20 years 20 grand a
year drug and do you have debt we do own
two vehicles that we go on I still owe
12,500 on mine and she owes $9,000 but
other than that we have no debt she does
plan on going she's going to school
right now and we do have to pay for her
last year of schooling without debt yes
yeah you're gonna pay cash for it okay
yeah what's she studying she's studying
psychology so do what she wants be a
licensed professional counselor okay I
just have a master's degree to do that
right yes if she plans on going straight
into her master's which we've been
trying to decide what's the best
financial way to go do that well there's
only one way and that's pay for it or
find the scholarships I mean going into
debt for a master's in psychology would
be ludicrous going into debt period for
a degree is a bad idea but that's a
really bad idea
well I wouldn't I
you know if you called me ahead of time
and said do I buy a house I would've
said absolutely not number one I will I
get married and I'm married a year and
I've got my finances stable and I would
rent something cheap and not be a
homeowner number two I would have you to
be debt-free and number three I'd have
you for having this education plan
figured out long before you buy a house
so how much are you putting down we're
only putting 5% down so so how much well
I think six seven thousand is over for
now where are you getting that all right
so I have right now about 10 grand in
the bank 3,000 investments then uh the
other 8,000 my 401 okay all right
well I would stop adding to your 401 and
I would here's where I'm torn okay Logan
no you should not buy a house you should
not buy a house but you gave your word
and I'm pretty disturbed about this idea
and that you can just walk away from and
break your word that bothers me so I'm
not sure that's what a contract is I
mean you shake hands you sign a piece of
paper and say I'm gonna do a deal Oh
change my mind
you know people get hurt when you do
that those are those sellers you know
they're expecting to move they're
expecting to use that money to buy
another house they have plans and and
now you're just gonna jerk the rug out
from under them and so I can't tell you
to do that I just don't think that's
ethical even if the contract allows it
the day before your closing that that's
that's not the way you do business it's
not the way you should behave so no you
shouldn't be buying a house but no I'm
not gonna tell you to just back out on a
deal that you said you were gonna do so
I don't know what kind of a contract
you've signed here I mean I've done
probably 3,000 real-estate transactions
and I've never had one that allowed me
the day before closing to just change my
mind without being in violation of the
contract without breaking the deal
that's just strange I've done stuff
where I had 30 days of due diligence and
I'm during that 30 days I can look the
property over I can decide what I'm
going to do on an investment property in
particular or development property and
I'm you know we can do soil testing we
can do all kinds of things during that
time I can decide not to buy it for any
reason but by the time I get up the day
before closing I've never been in a deal
where and if I was a seller I'd be
pissed so I just can't tell you do that
it doesn't feel that cold to me it
doesn't feel right but no you should not
be buying a house so I don't know what
to tell you to do other than you
probably ought to go ahead and buy this
house because you said you were going to
and then that's gonna slow down and mess
up some of the other stuff you were
trying to do but such is life you got
you got time to recover you're only 20